there goes the beds holy cow  [Music]  [Music]  we're good  [Music]  foreign  we still need to get down there that's  the thing we can't avoid it oh it's too  dangerous we can't go down there well we  as humans maybe can't go down there but  we can bring our technology down there  and send that data back so that it can  be used  so this drone can literally go fly  around the inside of a hurricane yes  what we want to do is fly in and around  those highest winds  foreign  [Music]  is the storm right now and how strong  will the storm become  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  by having these observations that we  would otherwise not have we can tell the  forecasters and the emergency managers  that make these life or death decisions  of evacuating or not if the storm is as  strong or weaker than they think